that was uh supposed to be welcome to
ask ij backwards but obviously
i didn't do very well you guys may have
seen this video of this girl who was
literally reciting any word backwards
within three
seconds and every single time it's right
burritos
pepsi is pep
bank
it's like she's not even real like she's
not a human liar
she is a robot she is not real ozark
crazy water
tall
oh water except we get the point
omniscient diagnose
okay just now you're showing off
whatever
can we just cue my theme music please
now oh i have control of that
hey guys welcome to ask ij i'm justine i
just seen ij is
first part of hijustine i was going back
through all of my old episodes of ask ij
and i realized that i've been doing ask
ij for almost three years now which is
kind of crazy and this is going to be
the 47th episode i kind of think i sort
of messed up somewhere but
it's sort of
it's
close enough anyway let's get to the
questions and of course if you're
wondering how you ask me questions
basically you just have to follow me on
all the random social networks that i
happen to be on and when i ask for
questions you just ask the question and
then i pick through them and then i
answer them
there's a little bit of dirt on you guys
this is not working oh do not shake hand
during use okay
twitter questions jeff burke b says
jenna date me
i rabbit wants to know how i like my
coffee i like my coffee just black
nothing in it just give me a cup of
coffee nothing in it bazz whiskey wants
to know about the wig model because if
you guys don't know there was this wig
packaging with a girl that looked just
like me on the cover which is kind of
absolutely insane because it looked just
like me well it turns out it's not me
it's a girl named jenna who is a model
it's kind of funny because my sister's
name is jenna
hmm beautiful hash favorite child's
movie beauty and the beast was one of my
favorite movies i also loved this movie
called camp nowhere i rented it on
netflix maybe like two years ago and i
never returned the dvd so i should
probably find that and really watches
it's probably i don't know the trickers
my opinion on bullying it is absolutely
wrong and if you're being bullied you
guys need to tell someone because that's
the problem people think that they can
get away with doing whatever they want
well you can't because you know what
there's people like me i'll come and
find you i'll come and well actually i
can't do that because then i'm bullying
i um i'm not gonna come and find you
what i am gonna do is suggest to you if
you are being bullied tell someone and
if you are a bully don't bully
alex on the couch how long will it take
me to finish skyrim oh i only have five
hours into the game and i probably won't
play any more than that but i know some
of my friends have beat it in less than
50 hours so
good luck to you
beauty wood hash didn't you just ask me
another question what are you asking me
would i rather lick dog poop on the
ground or eat a snake
i don't know
what should a guy do to take i just seen
out on valentine's day
leave a comment below where we would go
if we went on valentine's day i don't
care if you're a guy or a girl where
would we go what will we do please put
me in the next episode of ask ij
comments if you guys want to be featured
in an upcoming ask aj episode and like
these other fantastic comments be sure
to leave a comment below saying hi jay
please put me in a future episode of ask
ij facebook questions taylor i've ever
been to kennywood i have and for those
of you guys that don't know what
kennywood is it's an amusement park in
pittsburgh and if anyone has seen the
movie adventure land kennywood was the
theme park that they used there's like a
0.5 second clip in the movie where you
can see the back of my head it's great
you guys in this cinnamon challenge let
me tell you what if i do do it i'm gonna
need to have somebody here because i'm
afraid that i'm gonna swallow too much
cinnamon and probably
have to be taken to the hospital so i
don't want to do it alone it'd be like
that commercial where the poor woman
she's on the ground and she's like
pushing that button like calling for
help like that's gonna be me falling
and i can't get up except i'm not gonna
have a button to push i'm gonna be like
oh no i didn't fall and i can't get up
i've actually swallowed a whole thing of
cinnamon and i'm choking to death on the
ground we don't want that no mercer
wants to know what i do the week of
taking exams well mercer i'm not in
school anymore i've been in school for a
while so i'm assuming it probably
studied all right and that was supposed
to do dear ij what are your plans for
valentine's day do you keep asking me i
don't know i don't know what my plans
are i don't know you guys are supposed
to make the plans for me
leave me a comment evan yao justine can
we see your iphone case um yes you can
here's a little preview
instagram questions that's my favorite
game of all time oh my goodness mario
kart i've already answered this several
times but just to reiterate mario kart
all the freaking way across the sky all
the way across the sky
do i like to make whale faces yes i do
and for those of you that don't know
what a well face is it's when you get
really really close up to the camera and
you make the worst
hideous
face angle that you can oh gabe you want
to be my insta valentine that's so sweet
i wonder if my voice can get any higher
than this can it nope hit my limit
sarah
uh
this is a long one if you were an alien
from outer space you came to jerusalem
they asked you where you're from would
you say mars would you call your planet
something else
uh
i don't know
what's my favorite star wars character
absolutely love yoda and i didn't even
know that yoda died because i just
recently started watching star wars when
i found out he died i about cried my
eyes out
how did i get inspired to dance in the
apple store truthfully i don't really
remember why i started dancing in the
apple store i used to make a lot of
vlogs in the apple store so one day i
was just like i'm gonna shake my booty
hannah how do i have time to make all my
videos well uh
i don't know
considering that's pretty much my job to
make videos i have to make time for it
what's this one if you were the only
woman left on earth and all the men
wanted you who would you choose to be
yours well first of all uh that's that
would be scary can you imagine being the
only woman or even the only man left you
would be the only person that could
recreate the rest of the world it would
be a really slow process because if i
was the only woman left then i would
have to make a baby and then that baby
would have oh this is weird i don't
wanna
next question oh we don't have any more
questions so that's fantastic
well guys that's all the questions that
i have for you wait a minute you guys
asked me the question so that's all the
answers that i have for you guys i hope
you enjoyed this episode be sure to
subscribe so that you will know when i
launch other videos on this channel and
uh check out the rest of my youtube
channels in the meantime i'm gonna
go to the mario kart
whoa thanks for making it to the end of
my video check out the last one that i
created or my gaming channel or even
take a little peek at my daily vlogs and
uh don't forget to subscribe so you'll
be able to see all the videos that i
post on this channel from here on in
i'll see you
later
bye